surviving is the priority
sometimes we
we thought
this is the last second of our life
it was very scared
yeah but it was yeah they made sure
yodel the cat made it too but also
insisted the world needs to help them
now what should they do about
this should do
close
uh
they should close both these guys after
that we
maybe we can fight his footing
they're fighting the battle of their
lives but there's a sense they're only
delaying the inevitable
they're preparing to lay mines to
protect the capital road
and all the men escaping urban in the
west have their documents checked
and they're tested on their ukrainian
they're acutely aware here that russian
saboteurs might try to sneak into the
capital hiding amongst the terrified
civilians
so while the russians are still
advancing they take any window to get
people out any way they can
they've somehow survived the most
atrocious conditions in a town under
attack and under siege
but it's by no means over and from
somewhere they find the reserves to push
through this terror
because everyone here is horrified at
the thought of suffering the same fate
as other areas pulverized by the foreign
troops moving in
alex crawford sky news earpin
well we've had hundreds of questions
from you about the war in ukraine and
the security and defense analyst michael
clark is here with me now to answer as
many of them as we can you've can you're
very welcome michael thank you very much
indeed the first questions uh going to
come from me because we've uh just got a
statement justin from the polish
minister of foreign affairs it's
concerning the aircraft the mig aircraft
that they have and the uh the discussion
about letting the ukrainian air force
have them this is what the polish
minister of foreign affairs has had to
say the authorities of the republic of
poland after consultation between the
president and the government are ready
to deploy immediately and free of charge
all their mig-29 jets to the ramstein
air base and place them and here's the
bit i want to ask you about placing them
at the disposal of the government of the
united states of america this would be a
deal then that involves the americans
replacing those aircraft if they're
handed to the ukrainians one would
assume so if they go to ramstein that's
a pretty big base i mean i haven't heard
about this before but that would be
sensible and the mig-29s are aircraft
that the ukrainians can use it's no
point giving them other aircraft that
they would need some time to
re-familiarize themselves with they'll
know the mig-29 and the mig-29s they get
from nato
will be the best big mig-29s flying
because the russian airframes will have
nato avionics in them so it's entirely
sensible one assumes then that the
united states will compensate poland in
some way but i mean i think that's a
discussion for another day the main
thing as far as nato is concerned and
the u.s is concerned is get some
aircraft into the ukrainian air force
that they can use and the mig-29s is not
it's not the best aircraft around at the
moment but it's better than nothing but
in terms of what they're up against what
about the russian response i mean these
placed at the disposal of the government
of the united states of america well
leading member of nato how would the
russians interpret that they can
interpret the way they whatever where
they like i mean nato has been giving
arms openly to ukraine this is just
another type of weapon giving it to the
americans to give to uh the the
ukrainians is in a way is is to say to
russia if you want an argument about
this have it with washington don't have
it with us
i mean but if they were flying then
originally from an american air base if
they fly out of there again does that
have
a danger a worry about expanding the
theater of war
marginally i mean it's no different in
principle to having british um in-law
the the uh uh anti-anti-tank weapons um
sent by road into ukraine which we have
done and we will do more of this is a
bit more obvious if you're flying the
main thing is to make sure that
ukrainian pilots who may come into
western europe can find a safe way to
take their aircraft into ukraine and
they'll have to be a bit careful about
that they certainly won't advertise when
they're going to do it or where where
and how what routes they will use but
they will certainly give it a go i'm
sure well let's stay with the issue of
aircraft the first question that we've
received today at sky and users say many
many hundreds of people getting in touch
with us this one's from phil
asks uh can the un enforce an organized
humanitarian corridor there it is from
phil and that presumably would have to
involve aircraft as well and this is all
involving this issue of a no-fly zone
yes uh i mean the u.n
if if you and tried to enforce it then
it would have to come to the security
council for authorization and russia is
on the security council with a veto one
of the five permanent members who can
veto things so the russians would veto
it and remember too that if the u.n even
if even for some in some way the u.n
could authorize it
u.n forces can't be pulled together
quickly they usually take weeks and
months to come together even in quite
difficult circumstances and the
ukrainians need a humanitarian corridor
now this next 10 days two weeks so it
can't happen via the un in any practical
sense even if it could be authorized so
it has to come from the negotiations
that take place between absolutely the
only way humanitarian corridors of any
sort can take place is if the russians
are prepared to agree to corridors which
are established locally by the forces
who are there on the ground anyone else
coming in from outside will need quite a
lot of force quite a lot of
authorization and even then it might go
wrong so it's very it'd be very
dangerous to do even if it were
practical well let's address the no-fly
zone head-on we've had so many people
asking this we've heard it from
president zielinski today again we've
heard it from many of those people that
alex was talking to desperately trying
to get away from the bombing and this
from caroline says why don't nato
introduce a no-fly zone over ukraine for
even a couple of days to get people out
under humanitarian terms so you know to
to enforce those humanitarian corridors
yes uh again practical problems is that
any no-fly zone would involve
effectively declaring war on russian air
defense assets which are there in
ukraine and some some of those that are
over the border in belarus which are on
the border protecting russian aircraft
that are flying inside ukraine so
there's a difficulty there
it would it would invite
confrontation military confrontation
between nato and russia which in
principle would invite some sort of
wider european conflict the other thing
is that although you know we can all try
to think of obvious ways of doing this
the biggest suffering for the people of
ukraine is artillery it's not aircraft
it's not russian aircraft bombing them
it's russian artillery and russian
rockets which neither of which are
particularly accurate um and most people
who are suffering are suffering from
old-fashioned 1980s artillery shells
just let me ask you about that air
campaign is the ukrainian air force
still flying still operation because one
would have thought at the start of this
conflict that um the russians would fire
out number and outgun them they did they
should i mean they're more than twice
the number in terms of aircraft they've
got all of the modern the most modern
technologies and they haven't done it
the
what's interesting is the at least half
about something like that of the
ukrainian air force still seems to be
operating and they're doing pretty well
the russians seem to have a real problem
with their air with their air campaign
they're not conducting any complex air
operations they're flying low
and at night which means they fear
ukrainian air defenses which have been
really quite effective so low and at
night and in ones and twos they're not
coming in big complex formations where
they can actually take out a whole area
of ukrainian uh
forces or air defenses and so one of the
dogs that hasn't barked in this process
so far in the first 13 days is we say
where is the russian air force why
aren't they more effective a military
analyst has been asked we've been asking
ourselves these questions there are some
answers russian pilots only train for
about 100 hours a year all nato pilots
train for well over 200 hours a year
they never train on complex operations
nato pilots are constantly training on
complex operations between the members
of nato they go on these big multi
multinational operations british german
italian and they train all the time for
this sort of thing the russians don't
and so now they're being tested it
doesn't look as if they're doing
terribly well okay uh let's move on
we've had an awful lot of questions
about those chilling threats uh
overt or absolutely explicit from uh
president putin about the threat of
nuclear warfare and john asks this uh
could russia use tactical nuclear
weapons and or chemical weapons on
ukrainian forces cities and civilians
and if so would nato intervene so that's
a specific question we'll broaden that
out michael but from john there could
russia use these so-called tactical
nuclear weapons i mean that makes it
sound like you know they they don't do
very much they do battlefield nuclear
weapons they're also called they have
huge explosive power don't they do i
mean i mean even a one or two kiloton
weapon is is ferocious it's fearsome i
mean hiroshima and nagasaki were 15
kilotons which kills a city and so
battlefield nuclear weapons are
sometimes a one kiloton very that's very
small in nuclear terms sometimes five
sometimes ten but you're talking about
something up to hiroshima's um and the
russians have uh tactical nuclear
weapons right down to every level of
their forces most of them are fairly
small so and they have a doctrine to use
them would they use them i think that's
very very doubtful because that would be
the first use of nuclear weapons since
there we hope only ever time to be used
which is august 1945.
however if they take another step up the
ladder if everything else is going wrong
for them and quite a lot is going wrong
at the moment if they take another step
up the ladder you might expect to see
chemical weapons used because they use
them in syria for sure
and we sold the pass on chemical weapons
in 2013 britain britain and america
we were going to take action against the
use of chemical weapons in syria and you
may remember you were around in august
2013 and parliament sat that thursday
night and wouldn't do it and because
parliament wouldn't do it and britain
wouldn't do it the americans wouldn't do
it interestingly and that was it and
there's been quite a lot of chemical
uses since
uh seven or eight years later chemical
warfare is now a possibility whereas it
wasn't before 2013. can i just go back
to the nuclear weapon issue if um russia
used a tactical nuclear weapon within
the borders of ukraine what would the
west what would nato's response have to
be would it not have to be well look
he's he's he's broken that wall he has
used nuclear weapons the next one is
coming for berlin or london or
washington we have to make sure that
doesn't happen
the straight answer is i don't know
nobody knows
if if a nuclear weapon were used in this
circumstance however small
then we're into a completely different
crisis i mean this is not a nuclear
crisis this is a terrible crisis
mr putin is trying to nuclearize it to
frighten everybody but unlike cuba in
1962 that was a nuclear crisis that was
about nuclear weapons on either side
this is not this is about something else
he tries to nuclearize it by threatening
nuclear weapons by implying nuclear
weapons if one were used it would become
a nuclear crisis and then we're in a
different ballgame would nato respond
for sure it would respond would we
attack russia
almost certainly not in those
circumstances but if we thought russia
was about to attack us then the hair
trigger mechanisms would operate and
then we're back into a real armageddon
scenario
well let's ask you then if that
armageddon scenario came about another
question often asked let's get aj to do
this one for us what defense systems
does the uk have in the event russia
launches nuclear weapons towards us and
indeed the united states and others well
uh those of us of a certain age remember
ronald reagan's star wars program any of
those being developed and if so do they
work nope
um is there any defense no there isn't
do we have any defense against nuclear
weapons none whatsoever um because the
issue is what the view we take is the
view we've always taken it's impossible
to defend against nuclear weapons reagan
in october 83 declared the star wars
thing i was just going to the states at
the time i lived through all of that
it was all immensely science fictiony
and
none of it really worked i mean the bits
that worked were the bits that would
have worked anyway and there's no such
thing as as defense in space against
nuclear weapons and i could keep you
here all night telling you why not
there's about 100 different reasons why
none of it really works
um little bits of defense work you could
maybe defend yourself against one or two
nuclear weapons which is the system that
the us has got in place now but if
somebody wants to attack you with let's
say anything other than ten weapons let
alone the thousand or so that the
russians have got there's no defense
and so the the the thinking is that you
can't defend yourself so you deter you
simply say we can't defend ourselves
neither can you if you do it to us we'll
do it to you and deterrence has always
governments have always said oh yeah we
believe in deterrence we're very relaxed
about that british governments have said
for years we're relaxed about it it
works it shows it works well in crises
like this
people start to think a bit more about
deterrence and how sensible a policy it
is but there's no alternative because
it's the only policy any of us have got
okay michael on that note we're going to
take a short break plenty more questions
uh coming up because it's sky news
question and answer special you're
watching on the war in ukraine as i say
plenty more of your questions coming up
and we'll get the latest on the flow of
refugees coming from ukraine
[Music]
a more rapid fire but this is not this
is a conversation the format of the show
so we're gonna have an hour-long
interview show once a week on a thursday
night it's at 9pm it's a moment to press
pause on this frenetic pace of news and
just reflect on things and when we do
have a politician on the show you might
see them interviewed by me in a
different way than you perhaps normally
see it what they do
why they do it if i can find some of
that and bring it on to sky news i'd be
really happy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
well now the home office has sparked
anger after announcing it will create a
pop-up visa application center for
ukrainian refugees in the french city of
lille that's about 70 miles in land from
calais the french have accused the uk
government of a lack of humanity after
it emerged that hundreds of
refugees arriving in calais had been
sent back to paris to complete their
paperwork labor and a number of
conservative backbenchers are urging the
government to speed up the whole process
for ukrainians seeking sanctuary in the
united kingdom well skies laura bundock
is in calais and let's speak to her now
then and laura what have uh would be
refugees to the uk what have they been
saying to you in cali
well this is the hostel where many of
the ukrainian families have been staying
they've been offered free accommodation
and they've been offered help and advice
when it comes to visa applications
because i think they're realizing that
there is a real process when it comes to
trying to get into the uk many of them
interestingly have driven here if you
looked up the road here you'd see
several ukrainian cars and vans parked
along here these incredibly long
difficult journeys people now arriving
tired they're worried and still in a
state of shock we spoke to this young
family from keeve they'd left the
capital on the 24th of february they'd
picked up another family member and her
two young children made the long journey
arrived here in calais realized they
couldn't just get on the next ferry that
they had to apply for a visa and they
finally got an appointment in paris
tomorrow so they have to drive from
calais to paris hand over the paperwork
and they don't even think the visa will
be approved or they'll get an answer on
that tomorrow they'll have to make their
way back here to calais there is this
temporary visa application center in
lille being set up as you say but
certainly we've not spoken to anyone
here who's managed to access or find out
any more information about it and these
stories really are heartbreaking i spoke
to another young mother who was living
near odessa with her seven-year-old
daughter when she heard a bomb land near
her flat on the 25th of february she
realized she had to leave the country
and she told her daughter it was like a
game that every country they passed
through was another level in the game
every different bit of transport they
took was a stage of the game and they've
arrived here in calais she's left behind
her home she's left behind her job her
little girl asking her mum why can't she
see her friends why can't she talk to
her teacher who she's really close to
and these long long journeys you hear
about seem far from over when it comes
to what happens next and i i asked that
mum and asked her you know how are you
feeling tonight today you know arriving
in in france and she said it's simple i
don't feel lucky right now derma i
simply feel guilty
so upsetting laura thank you very much
indeed laura bundock there in calais for
us
let's put a question to michael clarke
about the uk's treatments of refugees
through the questions you've been
sending in sending in this one came from
christine which is why isn't the
government quite simple why isn't the
government helping the ukrainian people
and uh michael of all the things that
the uk seems to be getting right on the
approach to russia and ukraine this one
doesn't look that way does it 300
refugees were told accepted so far
compared to well hundreds of thousands
in poland even 2 000 in ireland yeah
i mean the government has got a lot that
it can take credit for in this crisis in
being first to recognize what was going
on sending weapons to ukraine helping
train ukrainians more than 20 000 of
them one of the reasons that ukraine is
doing rather well militarily is they've
received some pretty good specialist
training and we've been ahead on
sanctions and some other issues however
this is awful and this is a rerun of
afghanistan last year i mean in
afghanistan last year they had a year
knowing that the americans were going to
pull out and for that year they did
nothing other than a paper plan of what
they were going to do about refugees
which were bound to happen and when it
happened they were scrambling and our
performance last year apart from the
military performance getting 10 000
people out and they originally estimated
only 3 000 would need to come out 10 000
came out it was a mess and here we are
again
british and american intelligence last
december
said what was going to happen
and they've been right writing almost
every single detail so far and so the
british government of all governments
might have anticipated that there will
be a refugee crisis my students have
years ago if i'd given this to them as a
problem as i used to do would have come
up with this in 20 20 minutes and here
we are um scrambling for a response when
we've had four months to think about it
somebody else who knew it would happen
must be president putin he's weaponizing
people is he yeah and and this was
obviously the case i mean this is the
way the russians do things they did it
in chechnya they did it in syria they
know that that civilian populations are
part of the war plan and that sounds a
cruel thing to do and it's a it's very
hard thing for people like me to say and
a lot of people say oh no you're just
being very anti-russian but if you look
at the the way the russians think about
warfare it is really different to the
way the west thinks about warfare and
sure the west has been has been
responsible for civilian deaths in
afghanistan and iraq but it's never
deliberate it's sometimes negligent it's
very usually a mistake and it is always
it's always
a big attempt to actually avoid civilian
suffering even though they don't get it
right a lot of the time or some of the
time in russian planning civilian
suffering is part of the war plan it
always has been and it's a big
fundamental philosophical difference in
the way russians think about war and the
russians have thought about war since
the end of the second world war okay
michael a lot more to talk about but
we'll take a break uh you're watching a
sky news special on the ukraine war and
we'll discuss the next possible stages
in the ukraine conflict
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back i've got the defense and
security analyst michael clark here with
me to answer all your questions so many
questions
about the war in ukraine and another
theme that many of your questions
touched upon was how effective these
sanctions are against putin's regime
this was from gem
says do you think these sanctions that
are imposed on russia are making a
difference well we need an economist as
well here michael but um are they
because they're mainly economic i mean
they're coming in many forms and the
latest is this issue of russian oil but
clearly the squeeze is on absolutely and
the sanctions that are making a
difference are the ones that the
government are not taking or the
government are not responsible for
because the government have set off a
series of sanctions and so have other
governments the eu's done really well on
this one we're doing okay but again
we're taking it a bit slowly however the
sanctions that really matter are the
other private sanctions all the
companies that are pulling out of russia
the f1 the premier league all of the
organizations that are saying we don't
want to be toxically
uh connected to this country and so the
the the the sense of the international
pariah status which president putin has
got is now encouraging the commercial
world to pull out because they don't
want to have to justify to their
shareholders why they seem to be
complicit in what is a series of daily
war crimes going on on the european
continent russia has in a way gone back
to i don't know the pre gorbachev era
absolutely it it would be very isolated
now the the issue is the russian people
by and large don't blame putin for that
they blame us they they think it's all
america and that we blame them for
things that are not really their problem
but the middle classes know the
oligarchs know what this what the score
is and they understand that russia is
being isolated from the rest of the
world by this so yes sanctions are
important they won't change putin's mind
but they create a political crisis in
russia which is already well underway
putin's got himself a real political
crisis to deal with and just what about
the simple denial of funds this war must
be costing what some estimates are a
billion a day or more this this is very
expensive to prosecute it is except that
putin he's making a profit on this war
because the war itself has pushed up
energy prices so high
that every day
we send russia 700 million dollars in we
the the west that's 3.5 billion dollars
a week in energy uh money and so the
higher the prices of oil and gas go the
more profit he makes on it so the war is
actually very profitable for him that's
an inconvenient fact however
the fact that russia is going to suffer
economically for for all of this is a
sort of a medium to long-term pressure
which will contribute to bringing mr
putin down at some point in the future
okay michael uh let's get on to this
issue of nato we've touched upon it but
so so many people uh asking this about
the the role the potential role of nato
in the conflict and eva us is there a
point where nato could get involved
without russia having attacked a nato
country first and the russians certainly
say that uh nato got involved in
countries like serbia before without
being threatened in kosovo yeah in 1999
i mean nato had its own resolution in 99
and in 20 2011
acting on a very strong united nations
resolution nato was involved in libya in
this case this is europe this is nato's
own defense perimeter nato as a
defensive organization it would be
loathe to somehow become involved unless
it was protecting one of its 30 members
and the perimeter of nato as it now
exists so it's not out of the question
but it's beyond the level of
practicality that i could see for the
next two or three months at least what
would nato be preparing for an incursion
an attack on a nato member russia is
getting perilously close particularly of
course those baltic countries getting
particularly close to nato members yes
uh the three baltic states are really
getting very worried estonia latvia
lithuania estonia and latvia both got
significant russian minorities about 20
25 percent most of them were retired
soviet army red army people because they
were all retired to the baltics that's a
comfortable place to go so there's a
sort of community of ex-military who've
actually been manipulated a little bit
over the years lithuania doesn't have a
particularly big
minority russian-speaking minority but
there is kaliningrad which is a piece of
russia on the baltic sea that is part of
lithuanian territory and there's an
interesting little area called the
svalky gap that everyone will have heard
of in a couple of weeks time which is
about uh 60 miles long 30 miles wide it
is the gap of territory that
would link uh
kaliningrad on the coast piece of russia
with the border of belarus
and it is one of the areas that's
regarded as a european flashpoint and so
if putin went further than ukraine i
don't know why he would but you know
there's all sorts of scenarios if the
baltics were threatened it would be
maybe
as it were a sort of donbass situation
in estonia or latvia with russian
minorities becoming difficult or
some crazy attempt to link up belarus
with kaliningrad to link belarus and
this little piece of russia through the
through the slovakia gap which would
really bother lithuania and poland
tectonic plates moving uh another nato
question this one from john uh he asks
if we can't send in nato forces this is
a clever one why not send peacekeeping
forces from a
non-nato country um well uh nearby there
aren't too many finland sweden uh
turkish forces often get asked to go and
do peacekeeping duties but remember
peacekeeping forces only go when there's
a peace to keep
no sensible country sent its forces into
a war zone to separate the sides because
they just get obliterated if there were
a peace
and then a a peace to keep
then u.n forces might be uh developed or
deployed or independent forces but even
so getting peacekeeping forces together
isn't easy a lot of a lot of countries
with not very capable forces do it
because they get they used to get i'm
not sure what the current figure is it
used to be a thousand dollars per man
per month and a lot of them did it
because it was a way of paying for their
militaries so you get forces from all
over the world who just send infantry i
mean a lot of nigerian infantry turned
up in bosnia without uniforms without
any winter stuff and the u.n had to
supply them with equipment so a lot of a
lot of countries send forces for the
sake of sending forces to get a thousand
dollars per man per month
umps giving forces some of them do a
very very good job in a very brave job
some of them don't so i see but at the
moment given that there's there's no
place there's one and there's only one
aggressor russia would regard anyone who
enters that field as as part of that if
a peacekeeping force is feasible it'll
be in several months time okay well
let's focus now on some of your uh
questions about specific flash points in
the conflict we've uh touched on the
baltics uh darren asks how likely is
russia to take odessa and how big a blow
would the loss of it be to ukraine now
odessa that huge port in the south not
too very far away from crimea uh it's
seen as one of the key targets we
imagined for russia how big a blow would
it be yeah a big blow i mean odessa and
there's a odessa is the historic port
catherine the greats grapes you built it
it's a great um cosmopolitan poor it's
like marseille they say it's all the
criminals and and dealers and if you can
think about it somebody in the desert
will sell it to you it's that sort of
place very independent was never sort of
very pro kiev it was all very you know
they we are a destin that's what they
said they're very very ukrainian now in
2014
when crimea was seized a lot of people
in odessa quite liked the idea they were
quite russian pro-russian they're not
now and odessa the the mayor of odessa
said like other mayors i will make this
place into a new stalingrad and the
importance of odessa is that because
it's the port and with uh cherna morse
which is just about 15 kilometers 20
kilometers down the coast that's the
commercial port a desperate churner
mosque between them carry about 70
percent of all of the trade from uh
ukraine to the black sea and therefore
to the outside world and so grain bulk
goods all the stuff that ukraine sends
to the world including grain to china i
mean it's it's you know it's biggest
customer for grain is china
uh if that grain doesn't get out
world food prices all go up so odessa
and china most are very important
targets however
i think the odessans will they're
putting they're digging in pretty
solidly the ukrainians are moving their
best reserves to odessa they intend to
make a stand
and at the moment they're they're
they're fighting at uh mikolayev which
is a little way away and then unless the
russians can take mikolayev then they
can't get to odessa
if that fighter make alive has it's gone
back and forth in the last 48 hours if
the russians get past michelle which
they might they've then got to take on
odessa but isn't odessa vulnerable from
the sea as well presumably the russians
have control of the waters yeah yeah
they've got about 30 warships in the
black sea of which uh at least six are
assault ships and these assault ships
are pretty big and uh and they're quite
powerful and so there's a naval assault
waiting to go in on odessa when the
ground forces get there i i sometimes
smile because they've been waiting a
while and all these troops on the ships
would be getting pretty fed up at sort
of drifting around doing nothing very
much there is also a possibility of an
attack on the other side of odessa from
the the west from russian troops who are
over the border in moldova in the
transnational district so it's possible
that odessa could be attacked from east
west and south by the sea
it it it won't be a comfortable position
to be in but the odessans at the moment
are determined
not to roll over well let's uh go north
and talk about uh the capital and many
people wondering about the attack the
anticipated attack on kiev and perhaps
why it hasn't happened yet sir and this
question from peter says why can't the
ukrainians attack the convoy headed
towards kiev and we see a little bit of
it there and uh we've been talking about
this michael now more or less since the
russian campaign began it it stuck and
it's well and truly stuck isn't it a
sitting target it is and and it has been
targeted it hasn't moved for six days in
this form and the ukrainians are
targeting it they're not doing it with
lots of air power the way we might have
i mean as as was done on the road from
basra in the 1991 gulf war with the you
know
the road from bazaar um they're not
doing it that way they're attacking it
on the ground they're using drones the
bairachter drone the turkish drone is
very effective they've got their own
drone called the the punisher drone
little electric drone only carries one
bomb but it's very stealthy because it's
electric
it can't easily be picked up and what
they're being clever because what
they're doing is they're attacking the
fuel it i mean this convoy contains
about 15 000 troops it's basically an
armored division and probably about 230
tanks they're not attacking the tanks
they're attacking the fuel because the
convoys run out of fuel it's run out of
quite a lot of other things as well and
what they are doing they're holding it
in place by denying it the ability to to
sort itself out they're keeping the
traffic jam jammed
and latest information is this convoy's
trying to decongest from the back
they're trying to actually back up to
create a bit of space
um not doing very well what does it tell
us though about the state of russian
equipment as well some of it that we
we've seen some of the stuff that the
ukrainians have have blown up looks
looks pretty old looks pretty
dilapidated and some of it doesn't even
look military yes um the latest figures
i was checking before came the
verifiable figures from independent
sources or with photographic evidence
the russians have lost about 860 pieces
of significant equipment so tanks
armored vehicles artillery pieces the
ukrainians have lost 200 and less than
250
which they can afford but the russians
have lost 860. i was doing some figures
on this overnight
of those 860 pieces of equipment the
russians have lost about 60 percent of
them have been abandoned or captured now
any side retreating you would expect to
lose some equipment because you have to
retreat you have to leave the equipment
behind you try and blow it up disable it
and you clear off if you're attacking
you don't expect to have your equipment
abandoned or captured which indicates
that that ukrainian counter attacks
local counter attacks must be doing
quite well well let's abandon this much
equipment unless they have to that's the
equipment uh what about the personnel we
got this uh question from uh m asking uh
how many russian soldiers are being
killed in ukraine well we don't entirely
know but the russians it was last week
wasn't it said 498 you know it's more
than that what's the estimate ukrainian
ukrainian sources today say eleven
thousand
verifiable figures outside that are
closer to ten thousand now that's a lot
in in what two weeks yeah bear in mind
that in afghanistan in ten years eight
eight and a half years the russians lost
fifteen thousand men in afghanistan in
eight and a half nine years fifteen
thousand they've now lost ten thousand
in ten days in ukraine and that fifth
that loss of fifteen thousand back in
the 80s started to have a big effect on
on public opinion in the soviet union so
what effect 10 000 in 10 days will have
even though the russian public don't
hear much about this you know mothers
don't know what's happened to their to
their sons they don't know what's
happened to these boys and of course no
bodies have been brought back because
the russians took crematoria with them
mobile crematorium so that these bodies
are being cremated where they fall
they're not being returned home but
their mothers will wonder where on earth
they are okay michael we're going to
take another break we'll have much more
on that very issue what about
the effect in russia itself you're
watching sky news tonight and coming up
we will be discussing how president
putin might decide to end the war in
ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive degree
these
students the prohibitory order and now
they're going to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
welcome back to a sky news tonight
special because our security and defense
analyst michael clark is with me to
discuss some of your questions about
where the conflict in ukraine goes from
here well we've got this question to
kick off this section and uh this one
steve says other than a full annexation
of ukraine what are putin's other viable
exit strategies well clearly that was
the the initial ambition uh not going to
achieve that now we can tell that
because some putin's uh spokesman dmitry
peskov said the other day you know that
they would accept crimea and the donbass
and uh if you don't join don't join nato
but that shows that their ambitions have
dropped yes it also shows that putin and
the people who are close to the three or
four who he takes notice of were all
like 19th century politicians they look
at a map and say we'll have this bit and
this bit in this bit as if the 21st
century really never
existed um
putin has gone for broke in ukraine um
and it's not clear what his sensible
exit strategy could be
um he may have an idea that there's a
difference between east and west of the
nipper because east of the room the
nipper cuts ukraine in half
with a third to the east and two thirds
of the west the third to the east is the
more industrial populated areas more
russian inclined in history more i mean
half of the more than half the
population of kharkiv and mariopol where
they're fighting so fiercely are ethnic
russians more than half the population
yet they're fighting fiercely for
ukraine so he's completely
underestimated all of that however he
may think that that east of the nepa is
an area that he could control or even
annex and west of the nepa could be an
area for a new belarus a new puppet
government he might go for that the
ukrainian certainly wouldn't and i don't
think the world community would but that
might be interesting and this all
depends on how the fighting is going and
i'm going to put you this question from
craig which everyone is thinking as i
say 13 days into this conflict almost
unimaginable that we'd be asking this
question before it all started uh given
the the size of the russian forces that
were amassed on the border there and
this is how long can the russian
military run this operation and what
does a russian occupation look like and
you'd be talking about the attrition
rater among their troops among their
equipment
will they if it stays like this will
they eventually run out of material run
out of people
at the moment they're about to run out
of available troops uh because they
committed about 190 000 to this
operation and they're all now there so
they've maybe a couple of thousand held
back a few thousand but not many so
they're more than 90 committed to this
operation and it looks as if they're
bringing in more troops from the far
east with vehicles that are civilian
vehicles they seem to run out of
transport vehicles and these trains are
trundling across russia at the moment
they'll take four or five days to arrive
and it looks as if they're all going to
be in uh in minivans of some sort um
that's we'll we'll see what develops on
that but the problem the russians have
got in trying to occupy a country that
doesn't want you there every time you
make a gain you have to leave troops
behind to protect it you're not
liberating people so you can't keep i
mean when the allies liberated france in
1944 every time they liberated somewhere
they they moved on they moved on with
their full force they didn't need to
leave people behind now the russians in
a sense find that they've got three main
axes of attack through the kiev uh in
the south in mariopol to link up with
the north and in the west towards odessa
and all those lines of attack are now
kind of running out of steam um because
they're having to leave so many troops
behind and they're not really in control
the one city that they've got is cursion
in the south and they're not really in
control of that either okay michael uh
let's put all this together all we've
discussed in this hour and uh put the
big question that is on everyone's lips
i suppose and this from roy
what are the chances of putin being
deposed in a coup you've talked about
the the military setbacks
talked about the pressure yeah it's all
in terms of sanctions we don't really
know what the what the mood is amongst
the the oligarchs and amongst the those
that run russia but what's your
assessment of the chances of him going
he will i think putin's finished um that
he's he'll either go quickly or it'll be
maybe two or three years um who knows
but so there's no way of telling that
but he's finished
because this is a massive massive
strategic blunder i mean whatever you
think about the morality of it and the
rightness of it the wrongness of it it's
a massive strategic blunder which puts
afghanistan and iraq into the shade as
strategic blunders go
um there is no recovery from this
there's no way back for him now there's
there's not likely to be a popular
revolution in russia because there's no
mechanism for it and putin is not that
unpopular with ordinary russian people
out in central and eastern russia but
the middle classes don't like him the
the oligarchs are worried by him and the
oligarchs were happy to just get carry
on making money as long as he didn't
interfere with what they wanted to do
and now he is interfering in a pretty
big way with what they wanted to do at
some point
i mean his fate will be julius caesar's
which may not be necessarily a physical
assassination but somebody will put the
knife in politically when one person
does they'll all join in when that
happens could be in a month's time could
be three years time who knows but that's
the fate that now awaits him and only
china can save him only china can get
him off the hook michael you'll have to
come back to talk through that bit of
analysis uh michael clark thank you so
much for being with us and uh answering
so many of those questions on the war in
ukraine and you're watching sky news
tonight coming up in the next hour we'll
have plenty more as ukraine's president
makes history being the first foreign
leader to address the house of commons
[Music]
[Music]
you